and finally new rule tomorrow in honor
of Earth Day everyone has to shut up
about Mars shut up about Mars and how
cool it would be to live there and start
over someplace new
like where the Chinese moving to
Vancouver this is a dangerous idea that
our culture is already too taken with
that we can keep on trashing Earth
because we got Mars this fun new
happening spot come on bill don't be a
stick in the solar system red is the new
green
it's the party planet right next door
Mars or like Mars hola go it's
practically eaten if you don't mind
growing dinner in Matt Damon's poop well
I do mind
we need to quash this stupid fantasy
that Mars is a perfectly reasonable
planetary backup movies TV shows
magazines is this constant drumbeat to
get to Mars explore Mars colonize Mars
to paraphrase Jan Brady Martians
Martians Martian
Budweiser announced they're
investigating how to brew quality beer
on Mars something that can't even do
here
billionaires talk about March like it's
Margaritaville Amazon's Jeff Bezos wants
to go and so does Tesla's Elon Musk who
wants us to have a million people living
there in 50 years and says we got to be
a multi-planet species Richard Branson
says I'm determined to be a part of
starting a population on Mars
Richard here's a picture of you on earth
[Laughter]
here's you trying this on Mars
[Music]
to prove
even Donald Trump who isn't a real
billionaire but plays one on TV
favors Mars over earth his budget
slashes the EPA but last month he signed
a bill calling for a manned mission to
Mars by 2033 which NASA estimates would
cost 450 billion dollars here's a crazy
idea
if we're going to take up the challenge
to overhaul a planet let's do this one
[Applause]
let me spell this out in terms simple
enough for Steve Doocy to understand so
he can explain it to Donald Trump Mars
is an airless lifeless freezing [ __ ]
it's Antarctica crust with Casey
Anthony's trunk I mean just for starters
I'm a big fan of some Earth only
attractions like breathing this is kind
of a must with me when I book travel
they almost always throw in oxygen which
Mars has none of and if your spacesuit
gets a small rip in it carbon dioxide
will mix with your oxygen causing your
skin to dry up your brain to shrink your
hair to whiten and your eyes to sink
into your skull you'll look like this
[Applause]
it's through your eardrums would rupture
and the water on your eyes would
dissolve so with the water in your mouth
when you opened it to say ow my eyes the
temperature on Mars at night runs a
balmy 76 below to a quite chilly minus
225 so remember to bring a sweater hey
you want to explore something cold and
hard how about the facts
facts that confirm climate change is
killing us but completely doable
policies could reverse it we hear a lot
about putting America first let's put
earth first
[Applause]
millions of years of evolution shaped us
to thrive here and only here on earth
earth it's kind of essential would you
go see a band called Wind & Fire ladies
and gentlemen Mars is a mirage not an
oasis look at this scientific chart Mars
no air earth air earth food Mars
Matt Damon [ __ ] potatoes earth mostly
water Mars maybe a little water far
below the surface or maybe not in any
event don't bother waiting for the
Busboys to fill your glass Mars eight
months away by spaceship earth you're
here
you're here you're home stop looking for
the Goldilocks planet this is it Mars
doesn't have cool breezes or trees or
mangoes or butterflies there's no Cal
for liberals no opioids for
conservatives
there's no waterfalls no hot springs no
rainforests no rainbows in the greatest
song ever about the environment Don
Henley sang there is no more new
frontier we have got to make it here I
don't want to be a multi-planet species
[ __ ] Mars it's time to make Earth great
again
[Applause]
just here
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]